measures today
the president blasted the supreme
court's recent decision
striking down a 50-year-old ruling
guaranteeing women a constitutional
right to an abortion
this was not a decision driven by the
constitution
and despite what those justices the
majority said this was not a decision
driven by history
opinion polls indicate the majority of
americans agree with the president on
this
a respected pew poll indicating 62
percent insist that abortion should be
legal in all or most cases
despite this at least nine states have
banned abortion with more than a dozen
states expected to do so in coming weeks
flanked by his vice president and the
secretary of health president biden
insisted that it was up to congress to
pass legislation restoring roe v wade
and this in turn would need people to
vote for pro-choice candidates in the
november elections
the challenge is go out and vote
well for god's sake there's an election
november vote vote vote vote
consider the challenge accepted court
the president then signed an executive
order aimed at lessening the impact of
the court's decision on american women
it instructs the justice department to
ensure the safety of abortion patients
and providers
including setting up mobile clinics near
the borders of states restricting
abortion access
another part of the order directs the
health secretary to investigate how to
protect the supplies of medication and
increase public awareness around
reproductive rights the president has
also directed that access to emergency
contraception and iuds be expanded by
the federal government
this a direct response to what he
characterizes as a threat by a supreme
court justice
in his concurring judgment two weeks ago
justice clarence thomas suggested that
the court should reconsider the
constitutional right to contraception
even among married couples
mike hanna al-jazeera washington